gérard vous êtes co réalisateur du film
le démon de minuit avec marc allégret
pourquoi y at il deux réalisateurs sur
ce film c'est une histoire qui se passe
énormément en extérieur vous paraît-il
que je suis un spécialiste des décors
extérieurs et des décors naturels
alors on m'a demandé de venir pour
régler les mouvements de caméra
il faut tout à fait notre technique pour
tourner dans des décors dans des bars
dans la rue et je crois dans ce film ya
beaucoup de décors naturels ton est
beaucoup dans des bars notamment et dans
les rues oui on tourne au quartier latin
dans les bars on tourne dans les boîtes
dans les rues très sombre je crois que
vous êtes venu au cinéma pas du tout
comme les autres vous êtes venu à la
réalisation cinématographique en passant
avant par les actualités voulait nous
faire un petit topo de votre vie oui
j'ai fait la marche du temps pour maison
le film american et puis je travaillais
dans les actualités alors j'ai une
formation tout à fait neutre qui ne
ressemble pas du tout formation d'autres
metteurs en scène j'ai l'habitude de
travailler
la sauvette dans des conditions
difficiles dans l'évolution très très
difficile parce qu'il nous faut
énormément et les culés énormément de
patience il faut savoir attendre savoir
travailler avec les gens de la rue un
peu dans le style de la télévision il
faut des années d'apprentissage pour
pouvoir évoluer avec les gens qui
passent dans la rue des gens qui
s'associe à la réalisation d'un film et
je crois que maintenant vous avez tout à
fait abandonné les reportages
d'actualité séjour dire puisque vous
préparez un autre film tout de suite
après celui là oui je commence en
septembre à notre chine avec le même
moteur avec pascal jardin le piège
juillet pour cinq ans et vous allez
tourner aussi en décors naturels
oui je 70 des corps je tourne en italie
en bretagne par et sur la côte d'azur en
suisse à vevey
le film se termine hambourg port
d'hambourg et le film aura un titre
oui oui le gang via j'espère que nous
irons voir sur votre prochain film
bonne chance merci
[Musique]